le mec lui dit tu as un plan déjeuner et
lui il comprend les bancs gênés donc il
dit non
et après son pote le voit en train de
bouffer tu m'as dit que tu avais pas de
plans déjeuner dans un cabinet d'avocats
à New York c'est le handicap qui tue
bonsoir alors
Gérald c'est incroyable mais jusqu'à
l'âge de 33 ans vous étiez sourd sans le
savoir incroyable histoire pendant ces
trois décennies vous êtes adapté à ce
handicap et vous êtes même devenu avocat
au barreau de New York alors Gérald vous
racontez votre histoire dans un livre
intitulé La Vie malentendue publiée chez
Viber et à 20h dans Salut les Terriens
[Musique]
géraldc bonsoir bonsoir
alors jusqu'à l'âge de 33 ans vous étiez
sourds sans le savoir ce qui ne vous a
pas empêché de venir avocat d'affaires
au barreau de New York et de Paris et de
Paris bien sûr vous êtes né le 10
novembre 1942 à New York votre père
travaille dans le cinéma votre mère et
femme au foyer et vous êtes le deuxième
d'une fratrie de 4 un matin alors que
vous venez de fêter votre sixième
anniversaire vous vous réveillez avec
une varicelle et une scarlatine alors un
mois plus tard enfin guéri vous
retournez à l'école ce que personne ne
sait à l'époque c'est que la scarlatine
a partiellement détruit la partie de
l'oreille interne qui transforme les
sons en signaux électriques pour les
transmettre au cerveau vous n'êtes pas
sourd à 100% mais mais presque j'ai
perdu les hautes fréquences c'était la
partie bas de et les basses fréquences
sont restés plus ou moins intactes alors
bien sûr avant d'entrer à l'école vous
aviez passé un test d'audition mais
c'était avant la scarlatine donc
personne le sait alors à l'école vous
avez beaucoup de mal évidemment à
comprendre ce que l'institutrice vous
dit pour vous à partir de ce moment-là
les paroles deviennent une énigme à
percée le pire de tout ça c'est que vous
croyez que c'est le lot commun qui va
vous pensez que pour tout le monde c'est
pareil oui je pensais que tout le monde
devait faire le même analyse et j'ai un
terme pour les mots que j'entendais
c'est des lyrique par exemple j'ai perdu
mon château au lieu de j'ai perdu mon
chapeau voilà et donc il fallait que
tout le temps je transforme ces mots en
anglais et je pensais que tout le monde
tout le monde faisait le même exercice
mais que j'ai été plus grand que les
autres voilà alors vous devenez
effectivement une sorte de professeur
tourne seul qui comprend tout de travers
vous parlez bien je chante aussi je sais
bravo
voilà bon allez bien vous chantez bien
puisque vous avez appris effectivement
avant mais là vous êtes obligé
d'apprendre à lire sur les lèvres de vos
interlocuteurs vous en sortez bien les
résultats scolaires sont bons oui pas
mal c'était pour les lèvres dans les
étudiants
incroyable que ce soit la messe ou
baseball si vous comprenez à moitié ce
que dit le curé par exemple absolument
parce qu'au lieu d'entendre soit le
fruit de vos entrailles vous entendez
baby baby je répète ce que je répétais
ce que j'entendais exactement alors
personne n'aime pas vous-même ne
soupçonnez ces problèmes d'audition
puisque vous pensez que c'est normal
alors en famille on connaît les gens
aucun allait les voir c'est plus facile
je chantais j'avais peur des bruits
forts c'est un signe sur l'été et je
chantais je parlais bien et je ris
beaucoup quand je comprenais pas je
changeais le sujet et donc j'étais très
très heureux dans la vie dans la vie que
j'avais alors un jour un angle vous
propose compte tenu de vos performances
sportives parce que vous faites le 100
mètres en 10 secondes 8 ce qui est
absolument extraordinaire donc cet ongle
vous propose de postuler pour entrer à
la Philippe Academy un des lycées les
plus chers des États-Unis alors lors de
l'entretien le directeur de l'école vous
dit alors votre temps est de kiwi de
monde au sommaire en fait ça voulait
dire votre temps est de 10 secondes au
100m
l'exercice permanent vous obtenez la
bourse quand même j'ai obtenu la bourse
oui absolument en classe même si votre
moyenne a un peu baissé vous en sortez
bien parce que vous travaillez beaucoup
plus que les autres passer des heures et
des heures à lire vous apprenez même le
français absolument le français c'est
toujours l'histoire des voyelles je
connais les voyelles c'est les sons
principales de la langue et j'entends
les voyelles vous entendez pas les
consonnes et j'ai entendu parler
consonnes mais je vois que les Français
parlent je vois comme la bouche bouge et
donc j'ai appris la langue assez
facilement j'ai un tête musicale et si
on a ça et on a les voyelles et le
mouvement de la bouche on peut très bien
imiter je peux éviter le président des
États-Unis
évidemment il y a des fois Gérald où ça
pose des problèmes parce que un jour
vous comprenez que le prof vous demande
d'étudier les cinq premiers chapitres
d'un livre alors vous vous dites quand
même les cinq premiers chapitres vous le
faites quand même je vous êtes
intelligent et travailleur vous faites
quand même vous rendez compte après que
c'est les 5 premières pages voilà les
choses comme ça arrivait tout le temps
alors évidemment avec les filles vous
passez pour un doux rêveur votre petit
ami Elisabeth vous dit un jour tu es une
lurioscopée ça c'est curiosité voilà
bravo au cinéma c'est pas évident
surtout pour les dessins animés certains
jours vous expliquer à votre
live qui bouge voilà le cinéma c'était
Jean-Luc Godard une fille a une fly un
flingue c'est tout ce que je comprenais
pas l'amour parler du Bout parapluie je
vois des personnes qui s'aimaient qui se
détestent qui se tuent et puis la police
arrive et puis il y a lyon à la fin rose
et sa fin du film mais j'ai rien compris
alors vous faites des études
prestigieuses et après la Philippe
Academy vous êtes admis à Yelle et dans
les grandes salles de discours quand les
gens quand le professeur parlait je
comprenais rien je commençais à regarder
les notes et autres et donc c'était
perdu dans la grande classe dans les
petits mois mais j'écrivais encore une
fois je lisais beaucoup j'écrivais bien
les présidents
Columbia là les cours sont quand même un
petit peu plus compliquées qu'ayel et
vous mettez au point votre technique et
d'une technique extrêmement particulière
puisque vous notez les sons que vous
entendez et le soir quand vous rentrez
chez vous vous mettez au propre par
exemple si vous entendez si le chien se
lance en rentrant chez vous vous écrivez
si le client renonce donc écrivez tout
dans la journée finalement je me suis
décidé je devais faire ça et j'ai
traduisais le soir jusqu'à 2h du matin
en anglais alors ça marche vous finissez
pas loin de major de la promotion
à Columbia ce qui est quand même 7e
alors pour votre entrée dans la vie
professionnelle vous êtes recruté par
l'un des plus gros cabinets d'avocats
d'affaires de New York et là évidemment
le quiproquo se multiplie c'est marrant
c'est vrai par exemple le mec lui dit tu
as un plan déjeuner et lui il comprend
les bancs gênés donc il dit non
et après son pote le voit en train de
bouffer tu m'as dit que tu avais pas de
plans déjeuner dans un cabinet d'avocats
à New York c'est le handicap qui tue je
pensais que le but est réunions c'est de
mettre autour de la table
mais je pense que le but de la réunion
tout le monde se met autour de la table
et tout le monde dit quelque chose
inaudible et chacun retourne dans son
bureau pour essayer de comprendre ce que
on avait dit
et c'est dingue alors ce qu'il faut
savoir quand même c'est que quand vous
devez vous rendre un rendez-vous par
exemple quand vous prenez le métro les
bruits sont une torture intolérable
par exemple quand il y a une voiture qui
klaxonne à 100 mètres vous pensez
qu'elle est derrière vous n'arrivez pas
à apprécier la distance des sons en fait
voilà ce qui fait que pour vous une
sortie dans la rue ça devient une
aventure extrêmement
périlleuse les sons vous parviennent
sans aucune logique en fait absolument
alors vous faites des efforts permanents
pour vous adapter
mais bon c'est stressant de faire ça en
plus vous traitez des dossiers
incroyables avec des milliards de
dollars tu vois bon et vous êtes rongés
quand même par les ulcères à un moment
vous devenez malade vous avez du sang
dans vos selles à un moment oui voilà
j'étais très malade et un jour j'étais
dans la salle de bain je prenais de
médicaments et je me regardais dans le
miroir et je disais je veux mourir et je
sors du cabinet et je vois la société
président du cabinet et je me suis rendu
compte qu'il m'avait entendu qu'est-ce
qu'il fait gentiment ils vous envoient à
Paris j'ai pas compris ce qu'il a dit au
début au century à New York est-ce que
vous allez allez
au courant et au service au courant
Gérald je vous demande si vous allez au
bureau de Paris et je dis mais oui mais
je voulais l'embrasser j'étais ravi mais
une fois de plus et c'est très beau ou
parvenait à vous adapter et vous
travaillez plus que les autres à cette
époque là le pratique était plus simple
donc c'est plus un peu plus facile
normalement les ociations en anglais
c'était les conversations avec les
filles qui étaient en français et là je
me débrouillais très bien
alors de retour à New York 3 ans après
vous postulez pour un nouveau job chez
le géant pétrolier mobile et c'est là
que vous passez une visite médicale et
l'infirmière
vous fait faire un testif il serait
temps et c'est comme ça que vous
découvrez vous êtes sourd on va pas
sourd très sourd quoi alors je la
croyais pas à 3 ans je la croyais pas à
prendre un an j'ai rien fait pour ça
j'étais très content que ça et
finalement le chef mobile a insisté que
je regarde des procès-vabos et là j'ai
commencé à comparer ce qui se passait
dans les réunions avec que j'avais
compris tiens ces ingénieurs sont assez
intelligents après tout parce que je
comprenais le tiers de ce qu'on disait
et là vous finissez par accepter d'avoir
des appareils auditifs
et vous entendez tout ce que vous n'avez
pas entendu depuis la scarlatine la
grande beauté des adoles c'est que ils
ont réveillé d'un mois les sons de la
nature que j'avais dont je me souvenais
les criquets sont revenus de ma vie les
Piccolo les flûtes les violons de piano
tous ces sons de la musique et de la
nature sont revenus et je me souviens
souvenais à ce moment-là
et j'ai pleuré
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu